what's up everybody its Warren and we
have some insane news today James Gunn
is back to directing guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 he's back with Disney he's
back to directing the movie this is
confirmed by many many sources and
reports I'll break it all down for you
in this video a quick reminder about my
giveaway I'm giving away 5 imax tickets
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
so for those of you wondering if this is
actually confirmed or not it is
officially confirmed by Disney in fact
they stated that this happened a long
time ago months ago so it's odd that
we're just hearing about it right now
but James Gunn was said to have a pretty
big future with Marvel and Disney taking
the MCU into the cosmic future James
Gunn was fired in July so why the change
of heart by Disney according to Deadline
calm after the firing of James Gunn Walt
Disney Studios chairman alan horne met
with james gunn on multiple occasions to
discuss the situation persuaded by guns
public apology and his handling of the
situation after alan horne decided to
reverse course and reinstate gun mike
lemon jr. who works for deadlines said
that he spoke with Disney Marvel and
James's team and they have all confirmed
this to be true so the question is now
when will guardians of the galaxy 3 be
taking place James Gunn has already
signed up with Warner Brothers to direct
Suicide Squad 2 and this could have been
a really big problem but Disney has
decided that they will do guardians of
the galaxy 3 after James Gunn is done
with Suicide Squad 2 again James Gunn
was supposed to play a really big part
for Marvel and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe moving forward in fact he is a
producer on a lot of Marvel movies not
just the guardians movies and a lot of
people were really worried that
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 was not
going to be the same as the first with
the absence of James Gunn it is rather
odd that we didn't find out about this
especially since it happened months ago
but if you think back a lot of people
said that they're still using the same
script that James Gunn wrote they're
still using his story which makes sense
because if he's back you would use his
script you would use as
story so James Gunn is back to directing
and producing guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 great news to a lot of people who
thought that the guardians franchise
would not be the same without James Gunn
so let me know what you think about this
in the comments down below and let me
know how excited you are for guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 let me know in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to Marvel
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you